hello everyone and welcome to the last
day of the air things masters or rather
the last day of the preliminaries it's
the first game of day four and it's eric
hansen versus yanni ponyshi now you guys
have been requesting a lot of eric's
games and uh for good reasons he is
playing a great chess and he's having an
excellent tournament uh but uh there are
simply too many players and i can't show
all the games but uh now you know just
uh
to make up for it i chose uh uh well i
found a very nice photo of eric so at
least uh there's that uh so that being
said uh let's check it out and as nepal
is currently leading the tournament he's
seven full points uh like we said in the
previous video uh nepo is uh 27 points
and the magnus artemyev and vince and
camera are on 20 points so he is the
only one that's not really in any danger
of not qualifying for the main event so
even if he loses all the all the games
today uh he he
he's still in uh so he played a
spectacular tournament so far but so
he's eric so let's see what happens in
this game eric has the white pieces and
he opens with e4 uh jan goes for uh the
sicilian defense we have c5 knight to f3
e6 and now eric doesn't go for the open
sicilian rather he goes for g3 he wants
the fiance of the bishop and he will
have the setup that well we discussed in
in a few of our previous videos that you
can pretty much play this setup against
uh
against everything and it also works
against the sicilians so knight to c6
with bishop to g2 knight to f6 and now
queen to e2 we defend our e4 pawn and uh
as uh well white allowed it black will
execute the d5 we often say that if you
allow black to play d5 in the sicilian
then you no longer have the advantage so
here d5
e captures on d5 and now the position is
a known one and it has been reached many
times but the queen captures on d5 is
not the mood that is played here
everyone plays knight captures on d5 um
uh anand played that you did polegar
played it um a lot of very strong
grandmasters played it throughout the
years but here we have queen captures on
d5 by nipple
uh and it is now already as of move six
that we have a completely new game so
let's see how eric deals with this of
course knight the c3 can always win a
tempo on the black queen so you can play
it right away you can play it uh you
know uh later uh it is just not a great
square for the queen also you are in
front of the bishop so if the knight
moves also your queen gets attacked so
here uh hanson just castles we have
bishop to e7 and rook to e1 nicely
continuing development uh nipple castles
and b3 now still waiting with the
development of the knight preparing the
fianchetto of the dark square bishop uh
knight the d for now uh forcing some
traits attacking the knight and the
queen so knight captures and now we have
to capture with the queen as our queen
is hanging so queen captures on d4
knight to c3 and now rook to d8 and for
some reason um a lot of you have been
saying that there is no sound on the
previous video
when there actually is and then someone
else wrote in the comments that you
should just uh restart the video so that
brings the sound so i don't know maybe
it's a youtube issue no idea why uh but
yeah uh rook eight uh uh rook after d8
and now rook to d1 we still uh need to
defend this pawn before developing the
bishop because now it's attacked twice
so that's why rook to d1 we have e5 now
uh and here comes bishop to b2 and now
both of the bishops are nicely fianceed
we have bishop the g for attacking the
queen and you can't play f3 the f2 pawn
is pinned so here just the bishop to f3
and you can't play bishop to h3 even
though it could be
a nice idea as the b7 pawn is saying so
here in the upper just straight we have
captures captures and now e4 grabbing
even more space queen to e2 and now
bishop back to f8 it will be a very nice
defender here against this bishop so d3
uh trying to get rid of this pawn and
also open up rd file for the rooks e
captures on d3 rook captures and now
queen to b4 uh rook 8 to d1 eric doubles
up on the d file and now nipple just
trades rook captures on d3 rook captures
and rook to e8 and now both players have
developed all of their pieces so the
queen is attacked we have to move the
queen queen f3
and now uh we have h6 so we're creating
a a little bit of a breeding room for
the king but also having ideas of knight
h7 knight to g5 attacks the queen this
these two squares might be a little bit
weak as g3 was played also you might
have some ideas of bringing the rook
into the attack so this is a nipple's
plan so here king to g2 and then now
comes rook the e6 and uh
it's uh it's a nice idea although uh it
doesn't work and eric finds a perfect
way uh to
show why it doesn't work so feel free to
pause the video and find the absolute
best move for eric here while i give you
a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on realizing that
black's back rank is now incredibly weak
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is rook to v8 that's
that's the good stuff here as now uh
well this bishop cannot move and not
only that uh what can black play uh so
that's that's the the problem here so
congratulations to everyone who found
this idea uh you know always uh remember
uh what josh waitskin used to say uh you
know uh
what did he say
sorry uh the uh he often um spoke of the
square left behind and here okay it's
not that the square is important is that
the entire back rank was left behind so
that's why uh eric sees that and now
what can black play to give you an
example okay the b7 pawn is still
hanging but let's say you play something
like b6 uh we're going to play knights
to e2 go after the rook here and now
let's say okay you can trade queens here
still knight f4 attacks the rook uh and
after let's say captures captures it
seems like black you know figured
everything out but
what do you do with uh what do you do
with the rook here for example rook the
c6 if you put the rook somewhere weird
then we can even uh play bishop captures
here and just completely mess up the
black spawn structure now comes c4 and
look at this it's a really really bad
position for black the the bishop here
is a monster the the rook here
incredible uh the knight cannot move
otherwise knight is coming to d5 then
then to e7 uh black is pretty much
without moves here so instead after this
rook to d8 we have queen to b6 by nipple
but now he allows the other uh tactic
and that of course is rook to b8 okay
the rook is attacked we move it with
tempo but now how do you defend the
uh how do you defend the b7 pawn here
you could play a knight rook to a7 but
then knight d5 is very strong at forking
the rook and the queen and then after
characters queen captures uh you get
this position but still it's a very very
unpleasant and it's very similar to what
actually happened in the game after rook
the b8 rook the c6 was played now okay
you prevented the
uh anything from capturing on b7 but now
comes knight to d5 okay we have a trade
here a knight captures queen captures
and queen to c7 now getting the queen
into the game but now bishop to e5
defending our rook here so the queen has
to move we have queen to e7 and now c4
so very similar to the uh structure we
we mentioned but now uh look at this the
rook still controls the background the
bishop is a monster on this diagonal the
white queen is very nicely centralized
and black is really struggling to find
the move here so rook e6 attacking the
bishop just bishop to f4 we're still
waiting to pick up the b7 pawn and now
rook to c6 uh just uh
preventing the pawn from being captured
and now h4 eric will now grab more space
on the king side and the queen side
before uh
realizing his advantage so here king h7
uh we have h5 here and again nipple
without any any real move here tries g5
g5 is actually the strongest move
recommended by the engine so it's not
just lashing out because you're
struggling to find the move uh it is a
calculated risk that you absolutely have
to take so h captures and g6 alpha
king captures on g6 and now bishop to e5
uh grabbing even even more squares from
black so f6 and now bishop back to f4
but now you will play g4 you will gain
control over f5 over h5 and it will be
well very hard for for black to find
moves so here we have bishop to g7 now
comes g4 we have queen to e6 offering a
queen trade but eric of course declined
this queen to h5 check king to h7 and
now finally rook captures on b7 uh now
the the the blank the black king is in a
really terrible situation queen to e4
check king to g3 and now again it seems
like you maybe got out of the worst but
let's say you play something uh okay
let's say move the rook open up and
attack towards the black the white rook
now we've reached the position from the
thumbnail and you can simply play queen
captures on h6 the bishop is spinned
there's no capturing the queen once the
queen moves queen captures and g7 will
be checkmate so after came to g3 uh
nipple tried f5 yes now the rook defends
the h6 square but now we simply go into
an end game and of course it's a winning
one you force a queen trait queen
captures an f5 with check captures
captures king g8 and now rook captures
an a7 and now you are up too much
material you're up three pawns
uh and it's merely a matter of time
before eric wins but of course nipple
will try everything in order to prevent
this so here bishop e3 bishop c3 we have
king to g4 now bringing the king into
the game king f8 we have bishop
therefore now comes bishop to d4 again
attacking the f2 pawn bishop back to e3
bishop to c3 and now rook to d7 we have
king to g8 uh nipple can only wait and
see what happens rook to d5 now going
after the pawn
and rook to a6 going after the a2 pawn
so eric says okay we can trade i have
too much material anyway rook captures
on a2 now comes rook to b5 preparing to
push the pass pawn uh king to f7 now
comes rogue b7 check king to f6 and now
rook to b6 check we have king to f7
c5 now the pawn is marching forward rook
the a1 and here we have rook captures on
h6 and he was in this position on move
53 uh that yanni pony should resign to
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here as you can see white is just
up four pawns and it would be very silly
to continue playing this
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh finally we we see uh uh
well i managed to cover again by erica
so i hope you hope you enjoyed this one
even though there are so many uh great
ones to choose from uh a lot of you guys
requested his win over magnus but that
was a mouse slip so i decided uh you
know maybe it wasn't the the best game
to show him was a very early mouse slip
at that
but yeah very very nice win against nepo
uh really utilizing this um position
after rook to e6 because it's not easy
you can see that if knight h7 ig5 it's
already looking very good for black but
the the weakness of the back rank was
simply too much and black's position
just collapsed so that's the game i hope
you guys enjoyed it i would like to
thank david kimura doug reynolds even
sterling pp poopoo and richard schwartz
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot to really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of this spectacular event
until it finishes uh so thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day